All right.
Good evening, everybody.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliff.
I'm joined here by Theo Fields.
Say hello, Theo.
Hello.
We are here to present the fifth
workshop in the Creative Arts
Competition Series.
This evening we have
Miguel Rodriguez with us,
and he's going to
be taking us through
these fundamental pillars of
a non-profit business plan.
So we'll do a bit
of presentation
and then we will open
the thing for Q&A.
We'll have some really
lively discussion.
And with that, I will just
turn it over to Miguel
to give a quick
self-introduction
and then get us underway.
Thank you so much, Shannon
Rose, and thank you
for inviting me to be part
of this series of workshops
that you are offering.
I am the founder and
president of Athlone Artists,
which is an artist
representation agency.
It's a boutique agency
representing about 51 artists
so far, internationally.
These are classical musicians,
opera singers, conductors,
and stage directors.
I spent the past 25 years
working in the arts management
sector managing some of
Massachusetts most interesting
organizations, such as
Boston Baroque, where
I spent my last 8 years
before I founded my agency,
and Opera Boston, the Boston
Landmarks Orchestra, the Fuller
Craft Museum and a few more.
So what I figure--
I'm going to share
my screen because I'm
going to do a little bit of
a PowerPoint presentation.
I'm going to go through
it rather quickly.
If you have any
questions, please
do unmute yourself and say,
"Miguel, I have a question,"
and pop in and ask.
It's the easiest
way in this format.
And then we will
also have a chance
to have a little bit
more of a conversation.
So I'm going to share.
OK, here we are.
This here.
OK, today I thought that we not
talk about mission and vision.
Because I'm sure
a lot you've been
talking about this in
the past, and you're
very familiar with that.
But I thought I'd speak about
the long term and short terms
of planning for the
non-profit-- going
beyond the mission and vision.
The overview of the talk is--
number one, I'm going to talk
about building your team.
What does that mean?
What has been my
experience on criteria
for building the right
team for my institution
for my organization
for my mission?
Number two-- I'm going
to talk of building
your network of stakeholders.
Those are the people that
represent your market.
Who are you bringing your
services, or your product,
or your programs to?
And number three, I'm going
to talk about the sordid topic
of coin--
what we call the fundraising
part of the non-profit sector.
And basically, how
do we capitalize?
How do we infuse and inject
capital into our organization?
And there are two strategies
that I'm going to talk about.
First of all, fundraising.
And then I'm going
to talk about--
I'm so sorry.
I'm going to turn this off so
that we are not interrupted.
And then I'm going to talk
about the two strategies--
fundraising, which
is short term,
and then capitalization,
which is the longer term.
Again, this is a conversation.
Please ask questions.
There are many
ways to skin a cat
and I'm just going to touch
the surface of some of them.
First of all, talking
about building your team.
This is really important--
probably the most important
part of the startup process.
First of all,
choosing the people
with the right expertise.
What are the areas that
you need help with?
What are the things that
you need to accomplish?
And how do you get the
right people on board?
Over the years, I have been a
firm believer of Good to Great.
It was a book written
by Jim Collins,
and it helps you to think
about your institution,
your business, your mission--
whatever you're trying
to build as a bus,
and you need to get on the bus
the right number of people.
One of the things
that he talks about is
to retain the right
people before embarking
on any specific program is key.
You can't get started if you
don't have a bus running.
I always say, don't
look for compliments.
Look for people that complement
you-- not that are equals.
And what do I mean by that?
It's very easy, and I think
it's the most common mistake
for people to hire people that
have the same affinity of you--
that are like you.
It's easy to get along with
people that you feel have
the same type of mentality.
And, oh, so sorry about this.
Let me just quit this.
There we go.
So getting people who are
not just like you but who
compliment you.
What are the things?
What are the skill sets
that you don't have that you
need to bring on board?
I want to bring people always
into my organization who
complement what I don't have.
If my strengths
are programmatic,
and my strengths
are not analytical,
and they are not
marketing, then I
want people who are very
strong in those areas--
not necessarily people
who are similar to me.
The other thing--
your team management
should include people
who care very deeply
about what your mission
is, about your company,
and who will argue
passionately for the decisions
that they believe are right,
even if they disagree with you.
Another part that is
very important for me
is to make an assessment and
know the leadership styles
within my management team.
What do I mean by that?
Over the years, there have been
many ways to assess styles--
leadership styles.
And you want to make sure
that you have an array--
a variety of styles within
your management team.
The most four common, and
these have different names
by different theorists,
are directors, analyzers,
expressers, and harmonizers.
And I'm going to talk
about those in a moment.
And then the last thing
that I encourage everyone
to think about when
you are thinking
about starting an institution--
an organization of any kind--
is to think about how
does equity, diversity,
and inclusion become
part of your frameworks
from the beginning?
How do you create an environment
of equity within your team
and within your company?
And that includes your
stakeholders and your market.
And second, how do you diversify
in all ways of what it means?
Diversity-- not just racial
but age groups, skill sets.
All of that.
How do you create a
diverse environment?
And how do you become a culture
of inclusion within your team?
And you build that.
And that is something that has
become very important today.
And funders in corporations
and foundations--
they are all very
interested in learning
about the culture of equity,
diversity, and inclusion
within your organization.
So let me tell you about
what leadership styles and
what I mean by that.
There are four
leadership styles,
and when we talk about these,
we don't compartmentalize people
within one of those.
There are people that move
between two categories.
But let me just tell you
a little bit about them
and why they are important,
and why it's important for you
to know the leadership
styles of your team.
First of all, we
have "directors."
These are people who
are goal-oriented.
They are quick at
making decisions.
They are always on the go.
They tell it as it is.
If you give them
two choices, they'll
make a decision really fast.
These people get a
lot done very quickly.
Sometimes they can be perceived
as insensitive because they
don't dwell on the issue--
they create.
They look at the solution.
They make their
decision and they go.
These are very key individuals
needed in any organizations.
And CEOs-- a lot of CEOs--
and a lot of executive directors
fall under this category.
Number 2 are the "analyzers."
And I always think of analyzers
as the 180 degree opposite
from the directors.
These are people who
are very data-driven.
They are task-oriented.
They deal with process.
They know how to process--
how to create process
to get a product out.
They make lists.
They are called, also, thinkers.
These are people that
will review data over
and over and over, and they will
have a conversation with you
for 20 minutes about
one particular thing.
Analyzers can drive
directors crazy
because directors are
like, make a decision,
and the analyzer wants to just
go over the data over and over
again.
They are sometimes
perceived as procrastinators
because they take a long
time to make a decision.
However, directors
need analyzers.
They give directors
the right choices--
the right choices
to make a decision.
They are the people who
think the hardest about how
to solve a problem and what are
the repercussions going to be.
The directors will
look at that quickly
and make a decision based on
what the analyzers give them.
But these folks take
a little bit longer,
and you need to be able
to identify them and work
with them.
Then we can have
the "expressers."
These are, especially
in social services,
these are people-oriented
individuals.
They are animated.
They are entertaining.
They are the life of a crowd.
They are extroverts
most of the time.
They may be imprecise because
position and data is not
their focus.
They are more focused on
learning about the person
and learning about a
particular individual
and being attuned with them.
And they are a lot
of the times confused
with the "harmonizers," which
are the relationship builders.
These are the folks
that really, really
want to get people engaged.
And they are talkers.
They talk very
calmly and precise,
and they try to bring
people into the fold.
They are very loyal.
They are very dedicated.
They are conflict-avert.
They don't want to argue.
They want to figure
out how can we solve
the problem in an amicable way.
They may not over-commit.
They will not commit
at first glance.
They will want to see how
things are going to go.
These four styles live
in every organization
and hopefully they do.
If you have an organization
where all your teams are
directors, there is going
to be a lot of mistakes
made because there is
lack of data analysis.
They are going to not
relate well to their market,
to their stakeholders,
to their board members.
They are not interested
in relationship building.
They are short-lived and
one-term relationship.
They are too quick.
And so it is really important,
when you're building your team,
that you bring on
board people that
fill these categories-- that
fall into these categories
so that you have a very
diverse number of thinkers
and workers in your
team that can analyze,
that can build
relationships with folks,
can make decisions quickly.
And that is going
to give you an edge.
These are the people that
you want on your bus.
Let's see.
Building your network
of stakeholders.
This is very important.
This is how you
build the folks that
are going to be supporting
your organization.
They are going to be
folks that are going
to bring capital and
streamline sustainability
for short and long term.
Always remember that
everybody that you speak
to is a possible stakeholder.
These are people that share
your purpose and passion.
You should always
have a strategy
for first-time meetings
with prospects.
If you are going to meet with
someone for the first time
or you're going to
have a cold call,
have a strategy of
how you are going
to get this person
interested in your mission.
You've all heard about
the 60 second of the 30
second elevator speech.
There are many things--
practice those things.
You need to identify-- what
are the things that connect you
with those individuals?
What do you share?
I am always
interested in learning
what ticks that person.
For example, if I was
working at Boston Baroque
and I was meeting a
donor-- a possible donor--
for the first time, I'm
interested in what his history
is with Baroque music.
Because most
probably, this person
is a business person that
enjoys the music genre.
So how did they came
about to the organization
or to this music genre?
And what is it that ticks them?
I'm always curious about that.
Have a strategy for how
you're going to do this.
You should identify people
within your network--
that can be board members,
staffs, and stakeholders.
And learn how to use your board,
your staff, and stakeholders
as connectors to other
prospects and individuals.
This is a machine
that is ongoing.
It's a cycle that lives
in every organization.
And every CEO and
executive director
lives in this 24-hour, 365 cycle
of generating stakeholders.
Always try to connect with
each person in some way--
especially very important
stakeholders, important donors,
and possible investors.
I used to have a
little trick that I
used to play when I had
meetings with prospective donors
and I didn't know them.
It was my first time.
So I had a little folder that
I carry with me and a pad
where I would take notes.
And inside of it, on one
side, I had three pictures.
This is when I was
working at Opera Boston.
I had a picture of my dog.
I had a picture of my niece--
my young niece was 3 years old.
And I had a picture
of Beverly Sills--
a postcard of Beverly Sills.
And I would open it and
they would look at it
and they would go,
oh, is that your dog?
And then I thought, oh,
right there-- a dog person.
So we would talk about dogs
and get to know the person
and get to build
a relationship--
a personal relationship.
They would look at the
picture of my niece,
and they always
say, your daughter?
I said, no, that's my niece.
And I'm like, OK, children.
So children are possibly
an important aspect
of this individual.
Beverly Sills-- an opera lover.
OK, we're going to
talk opera today.
So find ways.
This is a practice and it
is an interpersonal practice
that you should always try.
And finally, I can't talk
enough about the power
of grassroots organizing,
even for non-profits.
Social media and building
a core of volunteers
are key for anything
that you do.
And the more you grow, the
more you want these things.
First of all, because
social media is
a powerful communication tool.
It allows you to bring your
message out and information out
very quickly to many,
many individuals at once
and people who are your
stakeholders at a very
low cost--
sort of a resource.
So I saw, the other day
I got an email blast--
a social media blast--
from a hospital
that we support--
a local hospital.
It was a picture of a
crane putting a CAT scan
machine, a big CAT scan
machine, into the building--
into the second floor building.
And it was just a
powerful message.
And the caption
said, "Thank you.
Your support made
it possible that we
were able to purchase this new
equipment for the hospital."
And it was all done
through social media.
It had hundreds and hundreds
of people saw it that
were their
stakeholders, and they
felt their money had
done something wonderful.
So, grassroots organizing is
very, very, very important,
and it's key.
Now I'm going to spend some time
talking about the "sordid topic
of coin," as I like to call it.
Most of you are familiar
with fundraising.
You've heard the word.
You know it's the thing
everybody runs away
from in the non-profit when
they don't know how to do it
or don't feel
comfortable with it.
There are traditional methods--
we're going to talk about it.
And then I'm also going to
talk about capitalization.
And capitalization
and fundraising
are two different
things in my book.
Fundraising-- they are
both two techniques,
two strategies, for short-term
and long-term sustainability
of any non-profit.
It is very important,
I believe today,
that you have a two-pronged
approach to sustainability.
One that deals with
the short term and one
that deals with the long term.
How am I going to
pay for or have cash
to pay for my expenses
over the next few months?
And how am I going to build the
capital over the next few years
to help me sustain
the organization
over the next few years?
So those two things
are important.
They are both
important, and they
are part of your institutional
relationship building process.
This is always ongoing.
And one does not
capitalize on the other.
The capitalization
strategy does not
take money from your regular
fundraising practices.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about what that is.
First of all,
traditional fundraising.
Most of all of us
are familiar with it.
They are fiscal year to fiscal
year to fiscal year strategies.
Meaning, if your fiscal year
is January 1st through December
31st, your traditional
fundraising strategy
is going to fund
that fiscal year.
In most non-profits,
especially in the arts,
there are certain categories
within the traditional
fundraising tools.
Number one is individual
giving campaigns.
That's the email blast
that you get from BSO,
or Tanglewood, or the Speakeasy
that ask you for money.
Sometimes it's
phone solicitations.
Sometimes it's a piece of mail.
It could be a card
or an actual letter.
More and more direct
mail is disappearing
as electronic solicitations
become more efficient and more
prevalent in the system.
We have a category
called "major gifts."
And major gifts is a part
of individual giving.
But major gift means that
somebody is giving you
a gift of a
particular amount that
is significant to
your organization.
That amount can vary.
For some people, a $100
donation is significant.
If most of your donations are
$5, $10, $100 is a big gift.
If you are an organization
that raises a lot of $100,
$5,000, $250 gifts, then
a gift of $500 or $1,000
becomes a major gift.
And that's coming
from an individual.
The interesting piece
about major gifts,
and the important part
is that they bring more money
with less amount of work.
It is very important to
have a grassroots approach
to individual fundraising,
where you have lots of donors.
But if you want to raise
$100 and you have a hundred
$1 donors, it is more
difficult to go and solicit
a hundred people than
solicit two people for $50.
So major gifts are
very important.
They also signal
to the organization
that this person has a
particular strong affinity
to your mission, so they
are going to be closer.
And a $500 gift can be turned
into $1,000, $5,000, and so on.
So major gifts are important.
They are personal, and sometimes
it can take years to develop.
Somebody who gives $10
today may turn into a $50,
or $100, or $1,000 later on.
It may require some stewardship,
and some conversations,
and some attention,
but you can build it.
Another source of
fund raising income
is foundations and corporations.
These gifts vary from
region to region.
Foundations tend to
be mission-driven.
Corporations sometimes require
marketing opportunities
for them.
In most places, they
are not the most--
the greater yield.
Most organizations, especially
in the arts in greater Boston
and New England, are mostly
supported by individual giving
and major gifts.
And then we have,
finally, special events
and affinity groups.
For example, a gala event.
These are social
networking opportunities--
people love a good party.
And if you can create a special
event that provides people
with opportunities
for social networking,
they'll be coming to your event.
They are usually transactional.
One time they may
come to your gala,
but they may not
give to anything else
that you have in
your organization--
any other opportunities.
But that is OK.
It's OK to have one-time gifts.
You could have affinity groups.
And what I mean by
that are, sometimes,
what they call
membership groups.
If an opera company or the
BSO has a young professionals
affinity group and those
are young individuals
under the age of 30 that
can give $250 a year.
So they create an affinity
group, and it's a membership.
It makes you feel like
you're part of something
and you're supporting an
organization you like,
or an institution,
and you're enjoying
having a group of individuals
with you that share
that affinity.
Some of these relationships
can be transactional.
As I said, it could be one time.
Some of them can be for
short-term relationships.
People and foundations change
their focus of giving often.
This year they
decided that they are
going to give to
organizations like yours,
and next year they are going
to give to social services.
So these things
are less certain.
That's why traditional
fundraising is important,
and it's at the core
of any institution.
But they can be less certain,
and they require resources.
You need to have
people dedicated solely
to doing this activity
of raising money.
The CEO, and the
executive director,
and the founder of
any organization
has to be intrinsically involved
in this fundraising effort.
it could be 50% of his
time, 60%, 75% of his time,
25% of his time-- it depends
on how good the fundraising
machine is in place.
So getting people who
know how to do this,
it's very important.
Now I'm going to talk about
capitalization campaigns.
These are more certain.
And the reason is that
this inflection of cash
is in addition to
what you do normally
on a traditional fiscal
year fundraising campaign.
So this does not substitute
the other-- this is on top of.
These are campaigns that
can be 2 to 3 year-- they
are multi-year.
They are not the same
as a capital campaign.
When you hear the
word, capital campaign
is either the company is
building brick and mortars,
either a building, or they
are building an endowment,
and it's a capital
campaign for that purpose.
Capitalization campaigns are
to enhance your institution
in the long term.
It's to provide security
and long-term institutional
sustainability.
They promote stabilization
because they are multi-year.
So you have an
influx of cash coming
over a period of 2,
3, 4, or 5 years,
depending on the campaign.
They are often
contracted commitments.
If you do a campaign
and you have
people who are going to give
you a particular number--
a particular amount of
money over 5 years--
then you draw a
contract that says,
"I have pledged to this
organization or to this company
my support.
Over the next 5 years, I'm
going to give $5,000 every year
for the next 5 years."
So you have $25,000
already committed
that is going to come
on a yearly basis.
So when you look
at the future, you
know that you have
some commitments
and some pledges on top of
your regular fiscal year
traditional
fundraising campaign.
You have an influx
of cash that is
going to make you more
stable as the years come by.
We're going to talk about
how you do that-- how
you make the case for that.
It offers the organization
the opportunity to innovate,
to create programs that you
cannot do with your traditional
fundraising, to produce special
projects that are one-of-a-kind
that are not going to
be produced every year--
but maybe you want in 2 years to
do a particular project and you
need to build the capital
now for that year.
It engages
stakeholders and donors
into really long-term
relationships, and this is key.
You start to learn
who in your network--
in your stakeholders network--
is with you for the long haul.
It's really, really good.
The other thing is
that donors love
to give money to organizations
they feel are going to make it.
If you are building your
future over a 3 or 5-year plan
and you're asking
for capitalization,
they feel like,
oh, this person has
long-term plans and a plan on
how to do that over the next 5
years.
I want to be part of that.
So capitalization campaigns
are, for me, are very exciting.
If you have a good
case statement,
they give you a lot of
security, and then it
allows you to plan more
than 1 year at a time.
It allows you to build an
overarching 3 to 5-year plan
with some real
capital behind it.
I'm going to give you an example
of a capitalization strategy
that I helped build for Boston
Baroque a few years ago.
This was about 4 years ago.
Boston Baroque is a almost
50-years old organization
in Boston.
They had been always working
on a year to year basis.
And there were some plans
that the artistic director
and the executive director
wanted to put forward
for the future that require
additional funding that they
didn't have from the traditional
annual fundraising campaign.
We call this the "Four
Pillars Campaign,"
and I'm going to show you
what that means in a second.
We put together
a case statement,
and a case statement is
key for any campaign--
any capitalization campaign.
It has to eloquently and
succinctly and specifically
define your goals
of what you want
to do in the campaign, how
you want to use the money,
and how are you going to build
the capital over the next 5
years or whatever the
length of the campaign is.
For this particular
campaign, at Boston Baroque,
this was a very rough
and initial look
at what we were trying to do.
And we call it the
Four Pillars Campaign
because they sustain the
missions and programs,
as you can see there.
Boston Baroque as an institution
is defined and put together
by its missions and programs.
And then the pillars
are the things
that make the mission
and programs possible.
There were four things
that we identified
through a strategic
planning process that
were key to the stakeholders and
the board of this organization.
Number one-- they had to do
with artistic excellence.
We wanted to become financially
stable over a long period
of time, not just
on an annual basis.
We wanted to enhance our
community and outreach
and education
programs, and we wanted
to enhance our
institutional visibility.
And I will tell you what
the specifics under each one
of those categories.
In each column, there's
a number of activities
that defined those elements.
We decided that this campaign
was going to be a $2 million
campaign to be raised
over 5 years. $2 million
over a 5-year period.
And what is this
money going to fund?
Well, on the first pillar, as
you see, artistic investment--
the artistic excellence part
column of this campaign.
We wanted to input an extra
$175,000 into our opera
productions to make them more
technologically interesting--
enhancing the quality
of the presentations
at a theater that
was not a proscenium.
We wanted to increase the
level of our guest soloists.
We wanted to bring
people who are working
at the top of their
artistic excellence-- that
are performing at the top
of America's theaters today.
We wanted to bring a
Boston Baroque, which is
a period-instrument orchestra.
We wanted to bring players
of particular instruments
that normally we would not
find people here in Boston.
So over 5 years, we were
looking to make a $600,000
investment, over
a 5-year period,
into our artistic product.
Then financial stability.
We wanted to put, over 5
years, a $500,000 investment
to stabilize the organization.
And how are we going to do that?
First of all, build capacity
over a 2-year period.
And when we talk about
building capacity,
means bringing on board
staff and team members that
can help us raise money--
but going forward.
So we would invest, over
a 2-year period, $150,000
to bring a couple
of new staff members
and then those people
will stay and become
part of the development machine
within the organization.
And then, we also wanted
to have some cash reserves
for the organization in case
things like a pandemic happen,
right?
You want to have some cash
so that you don't go under.
So we figure that
over a 5-year period,
we would raise $350,000
of a cash reserve fund.
The third one was community
outreach and education.
We wanted to invest $100,000
into free community concerts.
We were doing that
already, but we wanted
to build a residency program.
We wanted to invest $100,000
into our classics for kids,
commissions, and concerts, for a
total of $200,000 over 5 years.
Then, the institutional
disability part
was very interesting.
It was a category that
encompassed things
that we didn't know
what to put them under.
And we came up with
institutional disability
because, eventually, that's
what this was going to do.
Number one-- we wanted to
build three recording projects
over the next 5 years.
See the recording studio
recorded productions
of operas under our label.
We wanted to invest in something
that we call Boston Baroque
Radio, which is a 24/7 digital
radio station that we have.
We wanted to
establish a presence
in New York City doing
tours and having a concert
series in New York City yearly.
And we wanted to
have more run-outs--
more touring opportunities--
going to Tanglewood,
Ravinia, and some
of the summer festivals.
In all, the
institutional visibility
was a $700,000
investment over 5 years.
For the total of that
campaign-- $2 million.
So the question is,
OK, so you have a plan.
You know what you
want to do and how
you want to spend the money.
So how do you raise the money
on a capitalization campaign?
So we came up with
an interesting chart.
We figured, OK this
is a 5-year campaign.
We are going to raise
this capital over 5 years.
There in yellow are
the fiscal years.
In the first column
is, how many donors
of the different
categories do we have?
And we looked at our
donor pool to see
we could identify some prospects
and have our stakeholders help
us identify prospects and
then made a commitment.
These are the number
of people that we
think we can get on the first
year, on the second year,
on the third year.
And what you see happens is
that over a period of 5 years,
you bring all that
$2 million in.
On the first year
of the campaign,
we were able to bring $288,000.
On the second year, another
$385, and so on, and so on.
So what you're doing is
you're infusing capital
to your organization,
over a 5-year period,
above and separate from
your regular fundraising.
This is not easy.
It involves
everybody's commitment.
Most campaigns, capitalization
campaigns or capital campaigns
are done--
they undergo a quiet phase
for the first few years
until you have 50% of the
capital race of the commitments
race.
Once you have 50% of your
pledges, you go public.
And then people get very
excited and they want
to get you to the finish line.
But it involves extra
work and commitment, but
what you end up learning is--
who are the folks who have
interests in your organization
who want to become big
stakeholders with you
and want to give you a
sustainable plan over 5 years?
What are people's interests?
And these plans can change.
If in the middle of this
you encounter a pandemic,
you have to look at your
plan and make changes.
These are living plans.
So you're always
adapting and changing.
But you have a
purpose, and that is
to capitalize your organization
for whatever the reasons
that you want to do that for.
And I think that I'm
going to stop there,
and I am going to
answer questions.
And I know I've thrown
a lot of information.
Some of it may make sense.
Some of it doesn't.
So, I'm going to open it up.
And, Shannon Rose, you
can help with that.
Absolutely.
So I'm switching
us back to gallery
view so that we can have a
more peer-to-peer conversation.
This was fantastic.
So I think, before we get
into any of the questions
that I might have had,
why don't we open it up?
It looks like Evan
has a question.
Fantastic.
Thank you so much.
So I do have a question
on the last slide you had.
But before getting to that,
I'm curious as to just taxes
and different things
that 501(c)(3)s qualify
for, and interesting things that
we can do for our multi-million
dollar folks who are looking
to tax write-offs for $500,000
or whatever it may be.
So your question is about taxes.
So, non-profits are tax-exempt.
Anybody that gives
you a gift is tax
deductible to the
extent of the law.
I know that the laws have
gotten a little bit tougher
in the last administration, in
terms of the amount of money
that you have to give before
it becomes a write-off,
because the individual deduction
is higher than most people's
contributions to non-profits.
But they are all--
everything that you get into
your capital is tax deductible.
The only things that you
may pay some taxes on
are products such
as-- if you sell CDS,
there is some sort
of taxation to that.
It's minimum.
But other than that, any gift
is going to be tax deductible.
Is that the question?
Yeah.
I guess it's going
more into the nuances.
So I understand 501(c)(3)s
are tax-deductible,
but I'm curious as to the
specific brackets that might be
compelling to people.
It makes no difference
for me to request
$750,000 versus $1 million.
But maybe there's
some break at $882,000
that it actually
incentivizes that person
to give a larger donation
when it's on the bubble.
So let me just tell
you how donors think.
Donors don't look at the
bracket that they want to give.
They look at, how much
do I have to offer?
Most donors and
people of wealth who
have a philanthropic tradition,
they get from their investment
portfolio folks,
managers, and they say,
I'm feeling philanthropic.
I want to continue that.
You tell me how much
I can give every year.
The key thing-- if you have
a good development machine
in place and people
who are knowledgeable
about major gifts, they will
do research and prospect
each potential donor.
So the way it works is that
if you have a person, if it
is an individual, that you
are going to do a major ask--
let's say, do I ask for
$75,000 or do I go for $150?
You need to prospect
them, and there
are tools available to
development folks where
they can look at the giving
history of each individual.
Because every gift that
is given in the non-profit
is registered
somewhere out there.
So they can pull that data and
say, this donor's biggest gift
is $50,000.
So you don't want to overshoot
because it will turn them off.
Because then they'll think
that if you ask for $150,
and they normally don't give
more than $50,000, they may go,
oh, they're looking for
a bigger donor than I am.
I'm going to pass.
So you don't want to do that.
So it's not how they
fall in one bracket.
It's more, what is their
giving history and tradition?
And you need to do your homework
as part of your development
work on learning
about that donor.
What does he give to?
How much?
And then the tools will tell
you the most likely gift
that you can ask, and then
you ask for a little bit more.
If they normally give
$50, I would ask for $75.
And hopefully they'll
land somewhere in between.
Does that--
And then, in terms
of approaching
a foundation versus a
high-net-worth individual,
what are some
considerations that you
have from a tax standpoint?
The same way.
There are no tax implications
for a foundation.
They are also
non-profits themselves
when they're established.
It is all about their history
giving; how much do they have?
The foundations normally work.
We have a pool of money.
We have a million dollars
to give this year.
And how we're going
to divvy the pie.
Most foundations have an annual
report that will tell you,
in a pie chart, how much
they give to universities
and education, how much
they give to hospitals,
social services, and arts
and cultural organizations,
and then what your
slice of the pie is.
So that's how you deal with it.
It's exactly the same.
And most times, most
foundations guidelines
will tell you
their maximum gift.
Great.
Thanks.
So then you ask for
the maximum, right?
Absolutely.
Every time.
We have few questions
that Shannon Rose and I
have talked about.
Would you have any
other questions
from people who are attending
and not a workshop host?
OK.
Well I will--
I have a question.
Can you hear me?
[INAUDIBLE]
Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
My name is Joseph Webbie.
By way of background, my startup
won one of the MIT hackathons
in June in the
Knowledge Economy track.
And we're building a marketplace
to provide AI products
and services--
sort of productizing
it and removing
the friction for companies.
And over the last few
years, I did some work
for the Harvard
Business School alumni--
the community Partners Program--
where we volunteer and do
non-profit consulting for
non-profits in New York
City and the Bay Area.
And one thing I found
that's really common
is the difficulty
in these non-profits
with visualizing the
impact of their work
so that they can
raise more money.
Number two-- they don't
have a data strategy.
And number three--
they're really
bad with everything digital
marketing and social media.
So my question,
to you and Miguel,
is we're working
on a product where
we can allow non-profits to have
access to a data science team.
Sort of let's say on a
monthly subscription basis.
So let's say for $500, you
have one data scientist that
would work on a
visualizing all your work.
So I just wanted to get
your feedback on that idea.
I think--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--could connect with
you [? afterwards. ?]
I think the reason that you see
that non-profits are based--
and they work out
a mission ambition.
They have a mission.
One of the most common
issues that we see
is that they are program people.
If the mission is an
orchestra, they are musicians.
They don't know the
business side of it.
They don't know the tools.
They are not data
analytical people.
If it is a social services--
if it is feeding the hunger,
then they are program.
They don't know the
importance of data analysis
and all of that.
So, yeah.
So that's why you saw
that in your experience.
And these are really
great dedicated people
with great missions,
but they get
stuck in a cycle that doesn't
allow them to grow unless they
bring on board people with the
technology, with the knowledge,
and the skill to do
what you're offering.
I think it's a great idea.
If you can do
that, it'll be very
interesting to see
how difficult it
is for you to analyze
qualitative data
versus quantitative data.
It's easier to say how
many people we feed.
It's much harder to say how many
people we bring out of poverty
because that's a
different analysis.
But I think it's phenomenal.
I mean, what a great idea.
And yes, most small
mid-level non-profits
don't have the
skill sets for that.
Thank you.
I like the persona that you
mentioned of the analyzers.
So hopefully, if you can
please share your email,
I'd love to connect with you and
I'll share my product with you.
Thank you so much.
So piggybacking off of one
of those, I've got one.
Having a long and
storied history
in under-resourced
non-profits myself,
there's a baggage
element that surrounds
this lean, non-profit
mentality, and it negatively
impacts arts-driven
startup organizations.
So how do you recommend
planning, thinking,
budgeting for sustainability
to avoid the burnout
and other difficulties
that are all too prevalent
and the shortcomings that
were just brought up?
You need to think big.
If you are going to venture
into non-profit, think big.
What is the overarching goal?
How do you get there?
And then bring people on board
that can help you with it.
Most people who are founding
members or founding directors
of an organization, they
are, again, program folks.
They know how to do the product
that they want to create.
They just don't know
how to capitalize it.
So, it is hard.
You need to be entrepreneurial.
It doesn't matter if you're in
the arts, or social services,
or hospital.
You need to be entrepreneurial.
And come up with a business
plan that gives you
the capital that you need.
Don't under-fund.
Don't be lean.
You make your case to
every donor that you meet.
You know, I cannot
do it with $50.
I need $100.
$50 will not allow me to
survive going forward,
and this is very important.
You need to be very
compelling in your message
to every single person.
Then the other piece
is board members.
You need to build
a board of people
that not only believe
in your mission
but who can help you fund it--
who are connected.
And you need to be very savvy.
It's going to be a
mixture of people
who have capacity to give
you a big check and people
who don't have capacity but who
can make connections for you.
Learn the skills
that you don't know.
If you are starting a
non-profit and you don't know
how to ask for money, learn it.
It's not rocket science.
It's an art.
Ask for advice, get money.
Ask for money, get advice.
So when you don't
know a person--
ask for advice.
Call him up-- can I
have coffee with you?
I have a project and I
would love your advice.
And see if they get
interested in your project
and then get them on board.
Stewardship takes time.
It takes time but it has
to happen constantly.
And don't do things on your own.
Don't ever be alone.
Get a lot of people around
you that share your passion,
and then you can do it.
But don't under budget.
Don't settle.
Just be tenacious.
There is a good book call
The Ultimate Sales Machine,
and it talks about
pigheaded persistency.
I think it's key
in non-profit work.
That's really
great advice, and I
think that is definitely
applicable to all
different types of ventures
and all the different kind
of students who will be
competing in this competition.
And speaking of, if you have one
takeaway or one pearl of wisdom
that you would give
to students who
are looking to enter
a arts-related venture
in this competition,
what would that be?
I would say work from purpose.
What is your purpose?
I discovered mid
career when I was
debating whether to go
into political advocacy
or fundraising in
a more bigger way.
I went through a whole
executive training program.
In over the year
period of this program,
I learned what my purpose
was, which was the arts.
And it was music, and it
was working with artists.
And when I decided, yeah,
that's my purpose, then worked
from it, everything
fell into place.
I was very excited.
The interesting part is when I
talk to folks about what I do
or a product that I'm selling,
what they say is, wow,
you're so excited about it.
And I never think about
it, but I guess I am.
Because I'm working on purpose.
So find your purpose.
Work on purpose.
That's the number the one thing.
Everything else
will fall in place.
I couldn't have asked
for a better conclusion.
We're coming to the end.
If anybody else has any final
wrap-up questions for Miguel,
go.
Speak now.
Make yourself known.
Going.
Gone.
We will have Miguel share
his email in the chat.
I've popped his LinkedIn
into the chat as well.
We will be making the recording
of this video available
for asynchronous engagement.
We'll have a copy of the
slides that'll be available.
We're going to be zhuzhing
everything and putting
recordings up first
week of January.
If you're burning for something
sooner than that, please
send me an email.
I'll pop my email in chat.
And since there doesn't
seem to be anything else,
I'm going to close this out
with a big thanks to Miguel.
You hit on--
Oh, thank you.
--so many salient points.
The drive of this
competition is really
about strategizing,
storytelling, team building,
and articulating--
so many of the things
that you hit on tonight.
So I couldn't have asked
for anything better,
and it was wonderful
to have you here.
Good luck to you all
and happy holidays.